what's up guys bang bang is the Bitcoin
bear Market over what we're about to
find out Bitcoin is on the precipice of
closing four straight months up in the
green never in the history of Bitcoin
after four months up has Bitcoin set a
new low and so that must signal that the
Bitcoin bear Market is over if we are to
follow that historical Trend time will
tell not only that though we also see
that the Legacy banking system is still
in deep deep trouble First Republic Bank
they're trading like a coin
literally down more than 50 percent in a
single day this past week that is Major
trouble for a large Bank we already saw
the second and third largest bank
failures in U.S history earlier this
year and if First Republic Bank was to
fail as well that would be three of the
top five bank failures in U.S history
all within a four month period that's
not good at the same time that the banks
are under trouble we know that the
Federal Reserve has hiked interest rates
aggressively at the fastest Pace in
history and now people believe they may
either pause or start to cut rates going
in towards the end of the year Stanley
druckenmiller one of the best investors
in the world he's short the US dollar to
try to benefit if they actually do cut
rates if Stanley's right and the dollar
is depreciating and he makes money on a
short Bitcoin probably will go to the
moon on top of that Stanley
druckenmiller is not the only one who's
in on this trade Ted Cruz the politician
out of Texas he loves Bitcoin why does
he love Bitcoin he says he loves it
because the Chinese hate it literally
listen I like Bitcoin
for the same reason that the Chinese
communist government doesn't like
Bitcoin
they don't like Bitcoin and they banned
it because they can't control it
by the way I would note and you guys
asked me to be nonpartisan but I'm just
going to observe
China hates Bitcoin for the same reason
Elizabeth Warren hates Bitcoin
because they both want to control it
um and it comes down to fundamentally do
you want the government in charge of
everyone's money if you think about all
of the things that a centralized
Communist Party stands for it's
anti-bitcoin and so in some regards
Bitcoin is freedom technology and if you
like Freedom if you like democracy if
you like capitalism and free markets
you're probably gonna like Bitcoin
that's Ted Cruz's standpoint but let me
just put your mind in a blender for a
quick second the United States likes
Bitcoin but the U.S banks are under
trouble and we also see that there's all
kinds of abrasive regulation for Bitcoin
and the crypto industry and so that
makes it very interesting that Hong Kong
is opening up their banking system and
they're trying to solicit all of these
crypto companies to come set up accounts
there if the United States is going to
be hostile to this industry and China
Hong Kong and other places in Asia open
up their banking system that is a
cocktail for a disaster we don't need
that to happen that's it for this week I
hope that you all enjoy these up dates
I'll see you next Saturday